offensive d'ampleur sur barmut l'armée
ukrainienne est prise au piège après les
assauts
et de nous encercler pour nous faire
quitter la ville mais ça n'a pas encore
fonctionné bien sûr on a des pertes mais
on gère et on tient quoi
la ville de barmouth est un verrou
stratégique pour les forces russes
l'offensive est dirigée par les
mercenaires du groupe Wagner depuis des
mois la milice russe tente de prendre la
ville après avoir progressé la semaine
dernière sur le front nord ils sont
stoppés au sud lundi Moscou a revendiqué
la capture de krasnagora un village à
moins de 10 km du centre ville de
barmouth de son côté Kiev dit que ses
troupes parviennent à contenir les
avancées russes du moins pour le moment
je remercie chacun de nos soldats qui
empêche l'occupant d'encercler barmouth
qui détruit l'ennemi en direction de
volley-d'art et ne laisse rien à
l'occupant à part des terres brûlées
alors que l'Ukraine se prépare à une
attaque d'ampleur imminente il restera
environ 5000 civils sur place sur les 70
000 que comptait la ville avant la
guerre